European ministers responsible for
energy policy am and Luxembourg to agree
on new rules to make the use of biofuels
in the EU more sustainable and so help
cut greenhouse gas emissions the council
wants to finalize its position on so
called indirect land-use change this is
when farm lands used to produce biofuels
leading to food or feed being grown in
other areas like forests which results
in more carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
the aims to minimize the environmental
impact of indirect land use and
encourage more advanced biofuels onto
the market which will in turn reduce
greenhouse gas emissions energy prices
are also up for discussion the ministers
are set to examine ways to strengthen
the role rights and awareness of
consumers with a special focus on
combating energy poverty and helping
vulnerable consumers preventing the
disproportionate disconnection of
people's electricity is one area of
concern energy security in Europe in
particular avoiding any major disruption
in supplies next winter and the conflict
in Ukraine will also be debated Russia's
the e u--'s biggest natural gas supplier
and much of that gas transits through
Ukraine the two countries are locked in
a dispute over gas prices which is
simmered for several years and has hit
supplies into Europe in the past